hi I'm Bo Carnes and in this tutorial
I'm gonna be showing you how to create
Conway's Game of Life using react you
don't need to know a lot already but you
should be a little familiar with some
react concepts if you need to learn
about react or just need a refresher you
can check out my react basics video
which should be linked on the screen
right now also there is a github repo
that goes along with this so you can
follow along you should be following
along on your own computer but you can
use the github repo if you get lost so
you can check the link in the
description for that well let's get
started as you can see here the game of
life is a cellular automaton developed
by John Conway and it's it's called a
zero player game basically you set the
initial state and then you just watch
what happens so each cell on the board
has certain rules we go down here each
cell is going to live or die based on
the cells around them any live cell with
fewer than two neighbors dies as if
cosby underpopulation
any live cell with two or three
neighbors lives on to the next
generation
any life cell with more than three
neighbors dies as if by overpopulation
and any dead cell with exactly three
live neighbours becomes a live cell as
if by reproduction so just these rules
can create the board that's going to be
constantly removing so in this game we
have the play button we have a pause
button that's going to stop everything
we can also clear all the cells and we
can seed so we can just add live cells
and hit the play button and I can change
the speed to fast there's two speeds
fast or slow and then we can change the
grid size so here's the small grid size
we have to see it again and then here's
the large grid size so let's get started
on how to create this
okay I'm over in the terminal now and
I'm going to use create react app to
build a new react application this is
going to set up your development
environment so that you can use the
latest JavaScript features and it
provides a nice developer experiences
plus optimizes your app for production
so the first thing I'm going to do is
just make sure I have node.js installed
and I have version 8.0 point oh okay
good now I just have to install the
create react app so we'll do npm install
and create oh yeah yeah
okay that's installed now I clear my
screen and I'm just going to use create
react app to create our app so I'll just
do create react app game of life
okay create react app now just set up
everything for us
this just creates a default app and we
can actually run that by doing NPM start
nope we have to switch into the folder
first so let's do CD game of life now we
do NPM start so now we just go to
localhost colon 3000 in our web browser
and you can see the default page that
create react app made we're going to
make some changes to this obviously okay
I just open up our newly created folder
in sublime text you can really use any
text editor for this we're going to
start off by changing some things from
the default app so we're going to the
source file and I'm going to delete most
of these files so I'm gonna delete all
these files right-click the lead and
this file this file delete so all we
have left in the directory is the index
that CSS and the index J s and we act
most of our program is going to be in
index J s so we're going to go in here
and delete some of this stuff in here
and now we just have a really basic
thing so first we're going to import
react from react and import react Dom
from react Dom and we're going to need
those things to run react and right here
we have react Dom dot render app
document dot get ID bye-bye ID root so
if we go over to our public folder and
in index.html you'll see this is the
HTML page and down here we have the div
with ID root so this is where our entire
react app is going to load let's just
change the name instead of react app
game of life I'll say that let's go back
to our index and then just to see if
this works let's just try try changing
this really quick so we're gonna do P
hello world and we have to run our
server again so to actually see the page
that you're creating you have to have
this server running and it's going to
just automatically update the page
whenever you save a file okay you can
see it says hello world right on the
page so if you are using sublime text
for react
you should probably install a Babel
that's going to help with the syntax
highlighting for JSX so you're just
going to shift command P and then you're
gonna type package install package and
then when you have the list you'll just
do Babel now I already have it installed
but once you have it installed to make
sure it highlights correctly you should
go to view syntax open all current
extension as and here you can go to
Babel and then JavaScript Babel and you
can see the syntax highlighting just
change as soon as I did that okay and
react your page is made up of a bunch of
components and there will be components
inside of components so our main
component is just something that holds
the
entire page and then we're gonna create
a component that just holds the buttons
here then we're gonna have a component
that just holds the board the entire
board and then each individual square in
the board it's gonna be its own
component so let's start off by making
the component that has the entire page
this is just going to be called Maine so
instead of having hello world in here
it's gonna say Maine and right up here
I'm gonna have class Maine extends react
dot component so each component in react
is going to have a render method that's
going to render what's actually going to
show up on the webpage so I'm going to
start by writing that render and inside
this return is where I'm gonna put the
ASX
which is pretty similar to HTML to show
what's going to be inside the page
anything and your return method for JSX
it always has to be enclosed in the
exact same tag so there has to be one
tag that encloses everything so I'm just
going to have the div tag here let me
change my spacing here so everything
that we're gonna do is gonna be enclosed
in this div tag let me it's over here so
first we're just going to have an h1 tag
to give a title the game of life and the
next thing we are going to put in some
buttons right under the title but first
let's create a grid so inside a grid
we're going to pass in some properties
but we've sought to create those before
we pass in the properties let's just put
our final our final thing on the pages
is gonna at the very bottom it's going
to tell how many generations we've had
and to get how many generations we're
gonna have to create a variable or a
state variable that's gonna show me if
generations there are I haven't created
that yet but we're just gonna put it in
here as this that state that generation
in react pretty much all your variables
should be stored as a state or a prompt
a state variable belongs to whichever
component created that variable or
should be in charge of that variable so
each variable
held mainly by one component as its
state and if you're going to pass that
variable to other components that
variable becomes a prop all of our
variables are going to be stored as
state in the the main component and then
we can pass them to other components as
props so we'll see how that works in
just a minute here now that we've
started to create some state here let's
actually define the state we're gonna do
that in a constructor so go constructor
so in our constructor we're gonna always
going to start with calling super and
then we're gonna create our state this
that state equals and then we're just
gonna start with one thing generation
zero so we're gonna start at generation
zero and we're gonna try to get to the
point where we can test this as soon as
possible so the only thing we have to do
now is create a simple grid component
because here we're bringing in the grid
so since we're referencing another
component there has to be another
component for it to display correctly
so I'm going to create another class
here class grid extends react dot
component and we're going to have our
render method and inside we're always
going to return what we want to render
right now we're just going to return the
word grid
I'm going to save this our server is
still running in the console if we go
back to the browser it has been updated
so givethe says the game of life our
grid that from our grid component
generations and then zero remember
that's from our state we have generation
zero okay now we have a basic start to
our react project before we go any
further I want to create the CSS so as
we keep testing and we'll look how it's
supposed to look so I'm just gonna open
index dot CSS here there's already some
CSS here from when this was
automatically created so we're just
going to delete that and since this
tutorial is mainly about react and not a
CSS I'm just gonna paste in some CSS
here if you check the github link in the
description you can get a link to all
this code and you can actually copy and
paste the CSS for your file too so let's
move this over and I'll just briefly go
over this we're gonna use this
background image which is just a
repeating background image that I
thought would look nice for this program
the box is gonna be for all the box
components you can see with 15 height 15
so it's gonna be just a stock's and
we're just changing some of the display
and the border there's gonna be a border
so you can see it's a box and just so it
goes up against each other the margin
left and margin bottom is just so when
there's a one pixel border around the
whole box if there's not going to be two
pixels border when two boxes are right
next to each other and then we have a
box that's off is let me like gray a box
that's on is gonna be green and when you
hover over the box it's going to be a
color too it's going to be this blue
color now here we just have something
to center this is just a helper class to
Center content on our page and then all
the boxes are gonna be inside a grid
it's gonna be a 150 pixels wide and then
there's also gonna be a box shadow and
all these things are just gonna help the
boxes look correctly when they're inside
the grid and then all our headings are
gonna look like this except heading 4
we're just going to make sure there's a
margin top of 0 pixels so now the rest
of this tutorial will just be in the
JavaScript file all the other files are
completely set up how they're gonna be
set up so I'm just gonna hide the
sidebar so we can focus just on this
code here okay let's go back to the main
component and we're going to add some
more state variables and also we're
gonna just add some class properties you
generally want to have all your
variables as state variables because
when a state variable changes it will
automatically propagate through the rest
of your program and will automatically
update every place where that state
variable is but sometimes it's okay to
just use a class property or just a
variable right in your class and that is
that is when you're not gonna need to
have that propagate throughout the whole
app also if you want to reference a
variable when you first create your
state you cannot reference a state
variable from within your state when
you're creating the state that'll make
more sense when I show you we're gonna
have this speed equals 100 that's how
fast the program is gonna be running we
have this that rows equals 30 this how
many rows in the grid this dot calls
that's the columns it's gonna equal 50
and the reason why I don't have these in
this state is because I'm going to
reference the rows and the columns when
I originally create the state so I'm
gonna have grid full this is what the
full grid is gonna be like we're going
to create an array that's as big as the
rows variable and we're going to fill
that with a a map where we're
going to create another inner array
which as big as the columns variable and
each element in that array is false this
is just creating a 50 by 30 grid which
is a two dimensional array and every
element in that array is set to false
that just means every grid cell is
turned off to begin with so now that we
have these variables let's go back down
to our render method and inside the grid
we're going to pass these variables
these state variables and these
properties as props into our grid
component we're passing the full grid
we're passing the rows and we're passing
the columns so now we can use all these
things as props in the grid component so
up in this grid component first I'm
going to fill in the JSX that we're
gonna return and this is gonna use some
variables and some other things that
were then then going to create
afterwards so it's not gonna say grid
anymore cuz we're actually gonna put a
grid in there let's start by adding some
some things to this div so we're gonna
put class name now class name is just
the same as class but since classes is a
reserved word in JavaScript for JSX you
have to use class name so in HTML its
class J's X its class name I'm gonna put
grid now this is going to come directly
from our CSS so that's how we're going
to style this and we're also going to
add an inline style which is going to
equal width because the width is going
to change depending on how big the grid
is and this is just going to be a
variable that we still have to create
the only thing else we're going to do in
here inside the div we're going to put
the rows array now this is just an array
of all the rows in the grid which we
have to create and we're going to do
that right above the return method we're
going to create some other things first
of all the width so let's do a Const
width and it's going to be this that
props that calls so this that props that
calls is
from down here when we pass them these
rows and calls here this these become
props in the child component so now we
have this stop props out calls and it's
the same thing we've passed in from the
parent and we're just going to multiply
this by 14 and this will just get the
width that we need and we're gonna
create the Rose array so first it's
gonna just be an empty array and this is
where we're gonna add everything to the
Rose array that will show up in the grid
bar box class this is something we're
going to use while we're creating the
array and here we're gonna have some
loops here so for VAR i equals 0 now i'm
gonna have a nested for loop since there
are is a nested array and this next nest
is gonna be very similar to this so i'm
just going to copy that and this dot
plus dot calls instead of i i'm going to
do command d to select the next three
and switch it to j except this one needs
to switch back to i iterations like this
are commonly performed using the math
method over an array to map an array of
data to UI elements but to make this
more clear of what i'm doing i'm just
using two nested for-loops
but this would often be done with a map
we're gonna have let box ID equals i so
this is just going to create the ID
that's gonna go along with each box
element and the box class is going to
eat either be on or off so equals this
props grid full so we're gonna check in
the grid that we've passed in we're
gonna check at the specific spot in the
grid and we're going to check to see if
it's true or false if it's true that
means it's on and it's gonna be false if
the box is turned off this is gonna be a
ternary operator true box on
or false box off and this will just be
classes that we get from our CSS to show
what color the box is gonna be now we're
gonna start pushing things onto our
array and we can actually push JSX
right onto our array so that's what I'm
going to put here a box now we're
pushing a box component which we haven't
created yet but inside the box component
we're gonna have a box class this is
going to equal the box class that's what
we just created we're also gonna have a
key box ID which we just created and the
box ID which we just created so these
are both gonna be box ID row is I call
is J and select box so so far we just
passed in variables but you can also
pass in a method or a function that's
going to be called so this is going to
be this dot props dot select box so if
we're passing in this dot props that
selects box select box has to be a prop
well select box isn't a prop because we
haven't passed in down here so let's
just do that right now select box equals
this dot select box like said that's
going to be a function that we still
have to create we're gonna do that in
just a minute but first let's go up here
and finish off this box here so that's
the end of the box so we are pushing a
bunch of boxes on to the array and then
down here we just put that whole array
in here we can't see it quite yet if we
just save this and then we go into our
terminal oh and that was a mistake
that wasn't a mistake because I hadn't
finished it yet that was a mistake too
because I made a mistake if we go down
here this was supposed to be a squiggly
brace and now I'll say I'll go back into
the the terminal and now it doesn't says
box is not defined now this air is
because we still have to create that
we're going to create that next to the
code let's make the box
so I'm going to create a new class up
here this will be the smallest one we've
created so far class box extends react
that component just like the one right
below here and we're going to have a
render method and this is just going to
be JSX so first we're going to return it
div this is just gonna be one div
actually but we're gonna put the class
name which is just a class as this dot
props top box class and I did not need
these quotation marks and then the ID is
going to be this dot props that ID and
finally we're gonna have an on-click
function so on click we're gonna call
this dot select box now we did pass in
this dot props that select box but the
reason we're calling this dot select box
instead of this that props that select
box is because I'm gonna create its own
select box function right here Oh before
I do that though I am going to need to
end this div tag there's gonna be a
slash and then an arrow and let's put
semicolon there now here is going to be
the box's own select box function now
when we're creating functions in here
they're all going to be arrow functions
because we need to have the word this
bound appropriately if we don't make it
an arrow function when we write the word
this inside the function it won't be
referring to the right this this dot
props dot select box so we're calling
the the function from the props but this
time we're going to pass in something so
the reason why we're creating our own
select box inside box and not just
calling the prop
is because now we have to pass in these
things and as far as I can tell there's
no way to pass in anything to stop props
if it's inside the render method ok I'm
going to save this I'm going to save
this file and let's go back over to our
web browser got new err objects are not
values react child here's the problem we
have too many curly braces here so up
here we need two curly braces because
we're within a tag but when you're not
inside a tag
you only need one curly brace so let's
change this and we'll make a few other
changes I noticed I do need a semicolon
here and now let's save this and we'll
go back to the browser
it's loading automatically reloads and
you can see something the grid is there
as you can see we have this extra space
here so what we're gonna have to figure
out how to get that off now that seems
to have to do with how wide this is if
we go back into the CSS you'll see that
the box is 15 pixels wide and it's also
gonna have one extra border so it's
actually gonna be 16 pixels wide plus 1
pixel we have the negative 1 here but on
one side of the whole grid there's gonna
be an extra pixel there this should
really be maybe 16 because that's how
many pixels there are and then we would
just do plus 1 so let's try that 16 plus
1 save that and see what happens and
maybe I didn't need to add that plus 1
it looks like there's an extra dark line
over there I'm gonna zoom in really
quick oh maybe it's because I was
already zoomed in a little bit so that
if I'm at a hundred percent I don't see
an extra line so we just fixed that okay
it's time to add some methods to our
main component
you'll see that this unclick is this
that select box but this set select box
is this stop pop select box but this
select box is this stop prop select box
so actually this method is being passed
through to children components so it
comes from the main component then gets
passed to the grade component that gets
passed to the Box component we still
have to create it on the main component
you'll see on the main component all we
have is constructor and render we're
still going to have to make a few more
methods so let's create the this top
prop select box
so right under constructor I'm gonna do
select box equals now this is gonna be
an arrow function let remember like I
was saying it has to appropriately bind
this remember we can tell if a box is
selected in this array you can see when
we create the array everything's false
if a box is selected it will be set to
true so we need to update this array
with what has been selected and set that
to true so we are gonna select a row and
a call I forgot we pass in row call and
instead of updating this state directly
we're gonna have to make a copy of an
array and then do a set state command to
update the state in react you're never
supposed to update the state directly so
whenever you have an array it's best
practice just to make a copy of the
array first so we're going to do let
grid copy equal array clone now this is
a function I still have to create this
state grid full and so this array clone
function this is a helper function and
we're gonna have to clone an array a few
times so I just have this helper
function this helper function you can
see it doesn't have the word this on it
because I'm gonna create at the very
bottom outside of our component right
here we're gonna say this is just gonna
be a normal function you pass in an
array and to copy we just do this this
trick where you stringify it and then
you parse it and it will make a clone of
the array a deep clone if this wasn't a
nested array we could just do array dot
slice but since it's a nested array we
have to do a deep clone where it will
clone all the arrays inside the arrays
so let's go back up to here and we're
gonna set grid copy so we're going to
find the exact square that was clicked
and we're going to set it to the
opposite
so if it was true it'll be false if it
was false it will be true now this is
where we call the set state function so
this set state whenever you're updating
state you should do it through this that
set state okay let's say that and test
it out let's see if it works
compiling and loading it works if I
click a square it stays green so now
we're going to create two more methods
one is going to be to seed the board so
it will automatically start with with
random square selected and then we need
to have way and what some way to start
the game so right under select box let's
create seed and I'm gonna have to create
another copy of the grid so I'm just
gonna copy this line right up here and
now we are going to do some more for
loops because we're I'm gonna have to go
through every square of the grid and
decide whether to turn on or leave it
off
and then I'm going to randomly choose
whether the the square gets turned on or
not so let's create that function to
randomly choose something
so if math.floor math.random times 4
equals equals equals 1 so we're going to
create a random number between 0 and 4
and if it equals 1 we're gonna do
something grid copy equals true so we
have a 25% chance of turning on each
square in the grid Oh see this in
parentheses that actually should be at
the end of this if statement up there
and then we just have to set state I'm
gonna copy it right from up here this
sets a grid full to a grid copy now we
want the game to seed right away so to
make something happen as soon as
everything is loaded there is a life
cycle hook this is a method L run when a
certain thing happens so we're gonna use
component did mount so as soon as
everything's loaded it's gonna run this
this method here and everything inside
it so this dot seed so now if I save it
it should seed the grid let's see if
this works
nope let's see what we did wrong let's
say caesium even being run so let's do a
console that log and I'm just gonna say
seed so let's see it's compiling I'm
gonna have to open up the JavaScript
console set seed so seed is being run
but for some reason it's not working
correctly let's see if it's getting into
here
random okay okay it's not even getting
into the part where it assigns the
random number oh I have a parenthesis in
the right of the wrong spot so this
parenthesis here should go right there
okay let's take off these cons I'm
pretty sure this is gonna work so let's
take off these console that logs and
then we'll actually test it so save it
compiling and it's seated
it worked awesome now we just have to
make things move along so every
generation something should change in
here the squares should change based on
the rules we talked about earlier so
we're gonna have to set those rules up
right now so let's go back over to our
code so we're gonna have to have
something happen on an interval so we're
gonna have two functions one function
that starts the interval and then starts
calling another function that will run
on an interval so the first one is going
to be called play button because
eventually this will be associated with
a button a play button on the screen and
we'll set the interval ID to equal set
interval this that play this dot props
dot speed so set interval is going to
start calling this dot play at the
interval here this stop props that speed
remember we start started the speed off
at 100 so that's 100 milliseconds so
every 100 milliseconds we're going to
call this stop play and we're gonna set
this this that interval that ID because
that's how you stop the interval and in
fact if someone clicks the play button
we want everything to start over so here
I'm going to add a clear interval and
pass in this dot interval ID wait a sec
this stop props dot speed how did I do
that oh it's not a prop so it's just
this that speed
before we test this we have to create
this stop play this so let's do that
right below here
this is gonna be our main function for
making the game actually work we're
going to start by having two copies of
the grid so let G G for grid equals this
state that grid full and that's going to
be the first copy let G 2 equals array
clone because this has to be completely
different this that state grid full and
the reason for this is we're gonna start
changing the squares so we're gonna have
to check what the grid is currently like
and then change the squares on the clone
and at the end we're gonna set the state
using the clone now at this point I'm
actually going to paste in the code I'm
gonna paste in a little bit piece of
code and then I'll talk about it so here
is where we use all the rules from the
game of life from Conway's Game of Life
so we're gonna create these two four
loops that means we're going to go
through every element in the grid and
here is where we're gonna figure out the
rules so if we go back over here so here
I put in all these rules into the code
see if there's any lie cell with fewer
than two neighbors with two or three
live neighbours with more than three
live neighbours with exactly three live
neighbours and then we figure out if
it's gonna die or if it's gonna live so
the count is how many neighbors it has
so here we're going to go through and if
there is a neighbor we increase the
count plus one and since each cell has
eight potential neighbors you can see
there's eight lines here and this is
just how you check each neighbor and
then we have to decide if it's going to
die or live remember if there's less if
there's less than two or more than three
it dies if it's
dead and it has three neighbors it
becomes a live cell then we just do this
that state we assign the grid full and
then for a generation this that state
that generation plus one or we could
have put plus plus to increment it so
let's save that and we're going to try
this hopefully I did everything right
because if not we will be in a pretty
bad loop here okay nothing's happening
so let's see what we did wrong Oh
in component did mount down here I have
to add one more command this play button
to start the game so it's going to seed
it and then it's going to start the game
so now let's save it compiling and let's
see what happens as going
so we have some pretty cool things in
here unfortunately right now there's no
way to stop it so it's gonna basically
be going forever
we better create a pause button so under
this play button we're going to create a
pause button gonna equal this is pretty
simple we're just going to clear the
interval okay we already have two
buttons here we have the play button and
the pause button but actually we don't
have any buttons yet so let's add the
buttons now
I'm going to go back down to our render
for our main component and right above
the grid below the game of life heading
and add buttons this is going to be its
own component and we're just going to
pass in the buttons so play button it's
going to equal this dot play button okay
as you can see we pass in all the
buttons here and now we have to create
these buttons all these functions but
before that I'm going to create the
buttons component so let's go up here
and create the buttons component right
above the main component and inside this
we're gonna have a render method it's
going to return and in my buttons I want
to use bootstrap I don't to use
bootstrap to style the the buttons but
in react it can't automatically use
bootstrap so I have to install something
called react bootstrap so if I go to
this page here react - bootstrap github
- IO this is how you can get you can
easily use bootstrap and react so let's
go to getting started and I don't have
to do some things in the command line
we're gonna run this command right here
npm install save react bootstrap so
let's go over to our console I'm gonna
stop that and I'm just gonna paste in
that command okay got that install so I
have to go back and I'm going to get
bootstrap here so I'm going to copy this
I'm CDN for bootstrap go over to my toe
and I'm going to go to the index.html
and I'm just gonna put it right up here
so I've got the bootstrap in there I'm
gonna save that so now that I got react
bootstrap installed I'm going to have to
import some things from reactive straps
let's go
to the top here and we're going to
import I'm just gonna use a few things
and use the button toolbar menu item and
drop-down button from react bootstrap
okay that's all I should need to get
this to work so now I can go back down
to my buttons and start creating them
remember everything has to be wrapped in
a tag we're gonna use a div tag and
Center this is something from the CSS
there now everything is going to be
within a button toolbar and we're gonna
have our first button where we're going
to use a bootstrap class BTN BTN default
and on click we're going to do this dot
props dot play button because this is
our play button and it's gonna have the
text play and then we start to close out
the button tag and then I'm gonna paste
in a few more buttons here we have the
pause button clear button slow button
fast button C button with the on click
of the functions that we created in the
props and then we have one that's a
little more complicated which is the
drop down button so we need a title and
an ID and then we're gonna have an on
select function this that handle select
which we sought to create and actually
that shouldn't be parenthesis that
should be these curly braces so we start
to create that and then we have to put
in the menu item choices
so we have the choice 20 by 10 and let's
just duplicate that and event key - 350
by 30 and 70 by 50 and then we'll just
close out the drop-down button and we'll
close out the button toolbar and then
we'll just close out the div so now that
we have these buttons created we have to
create this function this dot handle
select so I go up to the top here handle
select
and we're just gonna call this that
props dot grid size and since we're
passing in something we can't do it in
the return render method we have to do
it in this method up here okay let's see
if they will let us see this yet
now I'm gonna rerun the server NPM start
ooh
Ric Bucher strap does not contain an XY
named drop-down button because I spelled
react drop-down button wrong okay so
let's go back up here and I'm actually
see if there's other place where I
spelled this so I'm do command D to get
every time I put drop-down button and
we're gonna spell it right drop-down
but button so that should have also
changed the ones down here yep so let's
try save on that again and compiling
again let's see if it compiles this time
compiled successful so let's go over to
the browser and okay we have a problem
super Express must either be null or a
function not undefined okay the problem
is that I this component here should be
a capital C so let's go back here
capital C and now I'm gonna save that
let's see what happens here it's gonna
refresh automatically and it works kind
of well the buttons are there this is
kind of off a little bit but we're on
the right track at least oh it's
probably because when we added bootstrap
it made some of the CSS kind of mess up
so we're going to try something over
here oh I'm gonna change this to let's
see 14 and let's see what happens here
looks good now we have all of our
buttons up here
so our pause and play buttons actually
work I always have to get the clear slow
fast seed and grid size buttons to work
so all of the functions are going to be
in our main component so let's just go
right down here and we'll start with
slow slow equals so we said to change
the speed so this dot speed is gonna
equal one thousand or one thousand
milliseconds and then this dot play
button
so it's just going to start it again
remember when you do the play button
it's gonna clear the interval and then
it's going to set a new interval with
the new speed here so it's going to be
doing basically the same thing if we go
back up here and see how our speed was
default to 100 we are going to set it
back to 100 because it starts at slow so
clear is going to be a little more
complicated but not too much more clear
we're gonna set this arrow function and
just like we set the grid at the
beginning let's go back up here I'm
gonna take this I'm going to copy it and
we're gonna do VAR grid equals and we're
just going to paste that back in there
now I'm not going to get to this in this
video but this would be a good place to
refactor instead of creating this array
two different times we could call a
function or somehow create it just once
and refer to it both times so that's
something you'll be able to do on your
own when you try to refactor this and
then we're gonna do this dot set State
and we're gonna do grid full grid
generation zero so I did the clear
function I think we only need one more
which is the grid size I'm going to
scroll down here grid size and we're
going to pass in a size we're not
actually what the size that we're
passing in isn't really the size
it's a number one two or three so if we
OH
first of all before I show you that
let's change the spelling of this grid
size so let's go back up here when grid
size is actually called we have this
that crops that grid size event this
event is going to be the event key down
here 1 2 or 3 it's gonna be passed into
the event here event so we're gonna get
a number 1 2 or 3 in the grid size
function down here so this is a good
time for a switch statement so it's
going to this side is either going to be
1 2 or 3 so case 1 we're going to set
this that calls to equal 20 and this dot
rose to equal 10 that's the small one
and then we're gonna have to break so
I'm going to select this and then
command shift D command shift D I
duplicated 2 times case 2 we're gonna
set this to 50 and 30 and then in case 3
or we can actually just put default
because that just means if anything else
comes through we're going to set this to
70 and 50 and we don't need the break
statement right here and then I'm going
to call this doc clear so this not clear
just going to reset everything and then
when it calls the this that set state
that's gonna end up updating
automatically the calls in the rows the
columns and the rows from here is
automatically gonna update to the list
at state and then that will propagate
through our app so we're ready to test
this out I'm just gonna save this let's
see if it compiles it compiles
successfully and let's try this out
let's zoom in a little bit I don't need
this
let's see pause play clear that works
I can seed I can make go slower can't I
hmm that doesn't even seem to be working
this stop play button is not a function
okay who you made a mistake over there
let's go back
so for slow and fast this is supposed to
be a lowercase P save that oh and I
forgot to make this fast here no wonder
you guys are probably seeing that
earlier
okay let's save that let's see if it
compiles and it compiles it should
refresh okay now let's try slow okay
it's going slower I like to test it by
creating this thing it's kind of like a
little spaceship and see if it does it
see if this works let's go fast and it's
just going to go across the screen
there's a few things like that that
people have figured out in the game of
life that if you make a certain pattern
etre just cool things you can see that
got to the end and just turn into a
square that's something that you can do
in refactoring right now if you get to
the end it there's no no squares over
here but you could refactor it to make
it so so this something like this would
go completely off screen so we can see
that while it's going we can clear it we
can see it let's see if we can change
the grid size 20 by 10 yep that'd work
let's see it it 50 70 by 50 that worked
let's see it play and here's another
thing you notice that when the grid size
is big this is
it's it's on the fastest speed but you
can see this is a lot slower than when
the grid is small so I've definitely
seen some game of life implementations
that go the same speed no matter what so
there would be another thing to look at
if you're trying to refactor my code
absolute you can kind of see why it go
so slow if I
open up the javascript console you'll
see these items hidden by filters if I
do default filter and I go to verbose
you can see the set interval is taking
too long it's only supposed to take I
think I think it's 50 milliseconds if it
takes more than 50 milliseconds it says
it's taking too long if we go to the
small grid side and Steve that see
you're saying it's not it's not showing
that at all now if we go to the medium
grid size anything over 50 milliseconds
is going to say it's taking too long
but that's not really bad that's why I'm
default doesn't even show that so as far
as refactoring of code that's something
that you can do to try to try to make
this run even faster so that's pretty
much it for the game of life we've
completely finished this you can check
the final code on on github if anybody
sees any mistakes or if you find a way
to improve this game just do a pull
request on github I'm gonna have a
special folder I'm gonna have a special
folder in the repository just for
improvements so if it's a mistake you
can do a pull request to the main code
but if it's an improvement you can
create a new directory in the
improvements folder and do a pull
request with your your improved file
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and remember use your code for
good